okay [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] it's your
boy psychobabble here with a man Donald
Trump right here and my luck lovely
lovely sidekick Gronk where is it there
is it over there um we're doing some
more main quest right now we're doing
get in a clue Oh so let's do that okay
uh yes yes hey guy here we go oh that's
a nice gun that's a nice gun um I it's
good we're using and also looking at
like oh no don't aim it at me okay I
can't detect a detective I had attacked
they attacked oh ok ok hello sir let's
do this oh she is hot look at that booty
it's really you well it's hard to
mistake this mug for anyone else hmm you
keep laughing at dad boobs I like this
they don't bras I guess with a patch is
agency and my job thank you no problem
baby yeah well come happy to do it yeah
scary pre will count to six ten yes I'll
jump in here prayer room what's it on
the table when you went out to find him
but you know if you're looking for work
and don't mind putting on the detective
uh-huh one case at a time Ellie our new
friend needs our help yes yes get down
to business take a seat yourself
comfortable i canna galantine okay when
you're trying to find someone who's gone
missing devil is in the details I'd
sutta stacked it
describe it can APIs there was a man and
a woman they didn't say much but I
remember they called me to back up so
we're talking a small team professionals
kind that know to keep their lips tight
when their own but what else can you
tell um we were in a vault what had
happened you were on ice huh more
importantly you were underground sealed
up and he's good again my wife was it's
okay you don't so we're talking about a
group of cold anything else you we're
looking for my son good question why
your family in particular why are you
gonna fix your [ __ ] face that this
isn't a random kidnapping whoever took
your kid had an agenda an anal agenda a
lot of groups in the car and out the
care that's [ __ ] up but with my ideas
what super mutants ganas so you think
this instant well they're the boogie all
diagnoses not easy to see why those
early models sense of their then you got
the newer models good as human and uh
huh first of all no one knows why they
do it what their plan is either way
you're right the speculation is getting
us off mmm the woman was dressed in them
maybe some kind of improvised the hazard
suit is interesting what else do you
refer simply forget that voice not much
to go on but a tough what else right one
of them came right up to me wait it
couldn't be
you didn't hear the name Kellogg it all
did you yes I tell me what notes do we
have the description matches bald head
scar recognize a bought a house here in
town right yeah that's right the house
in the abandoned wet stands the boy with
him huh hey that's how he lives they
both vanished a while back if I remember
lets you and I take a walk over to
Kellogg security doesn't really go to
that part of town but I always let's do
this it's all Nicholas ok ok I got my
gun this gun is [ __ ] all right I got a
bunch of shitty cup help you and Nick
final monster I'm gonna be a Monsuno
yeah vagina pretty cell ad ok ok at the
[ __ ] I'm trying to get in here kid
another waited there you go I'll move a
china monster a vagitarian idea well you
know and if you're on ahead they run a
little faster come on yeah there we go
moon and Jeff Anderson has he always
special one thing quick clean thorough
has no enemies okay okay come on hurry
up a little bit hurry up a little bit
there we go we got him around here we
got him running to kidnap a baby and
leaving one of the parents alive for
later many marks on the Commonwealth and
pull that off here we are keep an eye
out will you see if I can get this open
and I keeping an eye out ah Polly I say
of how I ok I can't come on come on oh
yeah why don't you no way I could pick
this no luck we'll need to find the key
and if I can break down the door
platform in the distance you're the city
entrance that's the elevator to the
mayors of us why don't you go ask around
there I'll stay here and see if I can
Jimmy this law
okay ack I just [ __ ] jumping all over
play Santa today mayor okay thank you
thank you maybe I gotta kill hood I
gotta kill her I'm press on this [ __ ]
crunk sorry crunk I get lindo like on
them though should I just kill everyone
in here oh that booty I could see that
[ __ ] I'm all away oh it's Piper easier
if you use softer words honey maybe
shout a little less so funny business
around the main got it ah yes I remember
you our new arrival i wish i was in you
and it's again in Callahan's killer I
see well whatever I can't allow you to
invade he's a kidnapper please mayor
McDuck oh I remember mr. Kellogg but I
in America I'm happy to help but I must
remind you not to get your hopes up mr.
Kellogg is long gone and not the type of
man pain away down here hey Piper oh
look who it is what brings you to the
mayor's office huh yeah fast what are
you doing here trying to find out why
the mayor happens to be meeting not from
any settlement an errand crowding the
reception area miss Piper the mayor
needs to make time for more
just [ __ ] jump right now how strong I
hate bats I can't I can't anyway it's a
keratin Anna Anna by a white [ __ ]
there we go there you go welcome welcome
tonight now huh how long must have left
some so sir take this God got ya let's
loot best place matches let's load this
I probably get a motion sickness ah-choo
as [ __ ] [ __ ] here nothing here to check
out that Jess and then [ __ ] here did I
check out this desk I [ __ ] took it
all I'm telling you something's not
right look for anything out of sorts
switch oh here we go and my way [ __ ] ok
guys I got a good gut gut get hey
Valentine I'm too busy loading it up
[ __ ] cabinet yes I'll can and I get that
last so stamp acts you know get this
down fear 44 caliber bullets and scars
San Francisco sunlights mmm interesting
brand won't lead us anywhere on its own
ah any suggestions what about dog why
don't you go fat before you head out I
know this is Hans you already have
plenty of [ __ ] cationic goodbye Nick
hopefully not forever good luck yeah
Jason okay Oh what the [ __ ] is right
here hey sir Santa Santa get Kellogg
chop always with away